want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
insight into how billionaires think to
get some success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one appreciate little things with
elon musk i'm just saying that you know
you want to take a moment to appreciate
things in life and the sensations
um
food's incredible
and like there's just so many good
things that you can experience
some of them cost nothing really
um you know
have a walk in nature or
uh just a nice meal and it's like wow
that's pretty great you know and uh we
should take a moment to appreciate these
these uh
little things the big things
um the things that move your heart i
think
that's probably the meaning of life as
close definitions as i can think lesson
number two make improvements with jeff
bezos i was in our
all the senior people at amazon do
two days of customer service training
every other year and several years ago
now i was in one of those customer
service
training sessions and i was taking calls
from customers i had an experienced
customer service
agent with me listening in helping me
figure out how to use the tools keeping
me out of trouble making sure that i did
a good job for the customer
and
the customer this particular call that i
got
the customer as soon as we pulled up
her order
the
experienced customer service agent
leaned over to me and whispered in my
ear
and said she's going to want to return
that table
she had purchased a
piece of furniture a table
and i was
and i so i'm talking to the customer
serv to the to the customer and the
customer says i need to return this
table
and uh
and uh it turned out that
the top of the table was scratched it
was packaged poorly
and
and uh and then so we finished up and we
handled the return and
and got all that done and i said to the
agent how did you know
that
[Music]
the customer was going to return the
table says oh that table always gets
returned
and so
that what does that mean that means that
you know there's not it's an anecdote
but if you systematize that kind of pull
back it means that the
that the uh
there's no communication flowing from
these people who are talking to the
customers every day back to our
fulfillment centers where the actual
shipping and packaging is going on and
it's very difficult
to get that communication to happen it
can't just happen
easily so we built a kind of inspired by
the idea of an andon cord where any
customer service agent can pull a
product off of the amazon website
if they
think that there's a problem and then of
course that sets in
that's having pulled that product off
that sets in place a whole series of
processes that go back but we're not
going to ship the same table to the same
customer over and over lesson number
three take care of your customers with
tillman fertitta you know the 99 95 5
rule there are no spare you know 95 of
everything we do is right every day in
business but look for the five percent
you do wrong and that's what makes you
better than everybody else there are no
spare customers okay it's a competitive
world and every one of our businesses
take no out of your damn vocabulary you
you're on a business trip and it's 1102
you hang up the phone and and uh on a
call and you call down to order some
breakfast and they say i'm sorry sir we
don't serve breakfast anymore that's
okay no problem i don't need a waffle or
or an eggs benedict just throw a couple
eggs and a skillet and send them up
scrambled however it's easy for you to
do i'm sorry sir we don't serve
breakfast why are you telling me no i
didn't ask you for anything special
you're gonna throw a burger in the pan
just throw me a couple of eggs and take
care of me be you're in the hospitality
business
okay and you're telling me no and
everybody's in the hospitality business
no matter what they do you take care of
your customer okay you take care of your
customers it's no different than we walk
in and your people meet us polite you
put a welcome up on the screen you come
in here everybody couldn't be can i get
you some water tell me can can i do this
for you you're in the service business
why do you want to be an ass and and say
no to somebody when it's just as easy to
say yes or do you just give an
alternative the company's being run by
somebody who's not
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four use a vision
board with oprah winfrey before we came
here deepak chopra
great thought leader of our times i had
called him wanting to do an interview
with him and he said he was going to be
coming to india and i i i have a vision
board i keep a vision board first vision
board ever ever started was to get
barack obama elected so i just had
barack obama
and then i went back
and that vision board was right by my
in my bathroom by the bathtub so every
morning i would say barack obama
president barack obama
and then uh this is in 2007 and then i
decided i had to go back and put 2008 so
that whoever was listening would know i
didn't mean barack obama president 2012
or 2016. so i only had that as a vision
and then i put a picture after barack
obama won
i put a picture i cut out of a magazine
of a woman
on a camel
in and it said come to india
come to india
and i've held that as my vision
on my vision board
for the past three years so when this
idea of coming with deepak i went now
it's time to fulfill the vision so first
impression coming in the city chaotic
and then being in the city with more
people than i've ever encountered in my
life
but still feeling not a sense of being
unsafe lesson number five don't look for
the perfect job with mark cuban now
let's pretend that you're just about to
graduate from college right what's the
advice
um you don't need the perfect job
you know um
part of the problem is you probably have
a hundred thousand dollars of debt right
um
and you gotta pay off for all that
um
and that's really [ __ ] up it's hurt
the economy it's hard you it hurts
everybody but
um
my advice general advice is assuming
there's not just the bills you got to
pay that are just
enormous is
you paid all that money to learn
now here's your chance to get paid to
learn and you don't need the perfect job
you need to get a job where you can make
some money
but also where you can learn and add it
to your portfolio of knowledge added to
your foundation because
as much as we want to think that we know
exactly what our mission in life is and
what our chosen profession is going to
be at 22
hell no there's just no chance that the
30 year old or even the 25 year old is
going to look back at the 21 or 22 year
old you and say oh that dude had it all
together and knew exactly what was up
right
he's going to look back and go beer palm
what were you thinking you know
and so
it
don't expect to have all the answers and
don't try to get the perfect job go out
there and get paid to have different
experiences and it's okay to jump from
job to job if it's not the right job you
are getting paid to learn flip it and
then use that to build your knowledge
and learn more about yourself learn how
to learn in business and see where it
can take you lesson number six use the
power of social media with grant cardone
i've created a fund called cardone
capital and it's changing the way people
can invest in real estate so when i was
growing up
and even earl in my early real estate
career i could not buy the best assets
the the best properties
are left for institutions at banks
and and it's super super wealthy i'm not
talking about
i'm done with the kind of wealth y'all
you're familiar with about and read
about here and i'm not talking about
people that have hundreds of millions
but billions and hundreds of billions
and even trillions of dollars of
available money to them
and so
most people
most even real estate professionals get
the leftovers
everything after that
and so i've been playing the real estate
game for 30 years and in the last seven
years figured out okay i'm gonna start
buying what jpmorgan buys in blackstone
and i'm gonna use my audience on
instagram and facebook
and i'm not gonna go get my money from
the institutions i'm gonna get the deal
from the institution
and the money's going to come from my
friends and we're going to crowdsource
this money
without paying brokers the brokers never
like to hear me say this
but we've raised 300 million dollars
bought a billion dollars worth of real
estate in the last 30 months i paid not
one penny to a broker
wow so that means all that investor
dollars ends up in the investment
saving the investor money and then we
distribute cash distributions every
single month
not every quarter like the banks
distribute every quarter or reit a
wreath will distribute every quarter
it's funny you know people talk about
the power of social media and they they
dis it a lot but
last week uh last week kylie jenner 600
million dollars 51 stake in her business
you have raised 300 million dollars
through crowdfunding
because a lot of people are wasting time
on social media they're getting likes
and comments i know there's a guy flying
into town tomorrow
and he's big on free and don't monetize
and and
he he's looking at his likes and
comments and i don't look at likes and
comments i look at hey i have an offer
this is what you could do it's a great
deal for you it's a great deal for me
it's a great deal for everybody that
plays and we want to monetize so i think
i'm going to raise 3 billion i'm going
to create a 10 billion dollar fund
crowd funding and then the banks are
going to come to me and say we want to
buy that thing and lesson number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is add value with vinod
khosla add some value
there's a true
societal and business value proposition
there's a contribution
i find
and i don't do this for
reasons other than the fact that you
can't long term
build a viable business without making a
real contribution
most people
look at
they can start a business do an ipo make
some money
almost always that leads to
businesses that are round trips what i
call good they go up and go down
to build a durable business you really
have to focus on the value proposition
one thing i really like about you is you
are unusually fearless and
willing to go in the face of other
people telling you something is crazy
and i know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out uh where does that
come from or how do you think about
making a decision when everyone tells
you this is a crazy idea or where do you
get the internal strength to do that
well first of all i'd say i actually
think i i think i feel feel fear quite
strongly
um
so it's not as though
i just have the absence of fear i've i
feel quite strongly
but there are just times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear
so speaking of important things like
people shouldn't think i i i should
people should think well i feel fear
about this and therefore i shouldn't do
it um it's normal to be to feel fear
like you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong if you didn't feel fear
um
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway yeah you know actually something
that can be helpful is fatalism uh to
some degree um if you just if you just
accept the probabilities um then
that diminishes fear
so
we're starting spacex i thought the odds
of success were less than 10
um
and i just accepted that actually
probably i would just lose lose
everything um
but that maybe would make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward
um so that would still do some good
um yeah same with tesla i thought the
odds of a car company succeeding were
extremely low what is your decision
making process or thinking when it comes
to investing your time your money your
energy sure
it's very important because time is the
most valuable thing you have is one make
sure where you're putting your time and
energy
is something you want to do
not just because you're exploring with
people you don't like or a business you
don't like or a situation you don't like
time is so valuable try and speak if
you're speaking to people or a situation
to people you feel there's hope for that
you could do something with to do
something great not just make money
whenever you go into business or in a
relationship with someone just to make
money then it means you've already
decided to take a portion of your time
to make these papers that are backed up
by nothing but will buy stuff
call it a possession
we have all these great possessions well
if you have these great possessions
could you give them away
if you had any possession you could give
it away hey great it was a possession
and you moved on if you can't give that
possession away to somebody
just give it away then it possesses you
well in my 20s and 30s i was fanatical
about software
you know i didn't believe in
vacations uh didn't believe in weekends
uh
you know i was focused on software uh
day and night you know i knew
everybody's license plate i knew when
they came into the parking lot when they
left uh
and i knew every line of code
uh
and it you know i enjoyed being a
fanatic uh
and you know i was really focused on
microsoft doing great software and you
know learning from our mistakes and
hiring the best
the best people i think i have to just
say
everybody is feeding yourself on
the hysteria and the negativity you
gotta stay in the light but one of the
reasons why i was so excited is about a
wrinkle in time because the message is
that the darkness is spreading so fast
these days you must become a warrior of
the light and the reason that's so
meaningful to me is because that's how
i've led my whole life and every moment
in that film i just felt like i'm just
saying what i've normally said it's true
and and for these times the darkness is
there to show you your light look at
what has happened so if you put the
focus on look at what happened with the
darkness that showed up in parkland and
the darkness that showed up on the
streets of ferguson the darkness that
showed up in many many many many many
many homes in chicago with shootings and
uh senseless murders
it brings out the best in people it
brings out the best and so that's what
it's there we live on a planet in
creating these companies that we thought
that we would be successful
i thought that the most likely outcome
was failure
but
but it was still worth doing even though
the odds of success were low in fact
even for for support spacex
the
originally what i started doing was not
creating a rocket company but but
actually was going to do
a small mission to mars which was just a
philanthropic mission where you would
send a small greenhouse with seeds and
dehydrated gel in the wood
upon landing hydrate the gel and you'd
have
this cool picture of green plants on a
red background and the public tends to
respond to precedence and superlatives
so this will be the first life on mars
furthest that life's ever traveled
um and you'd have this great money shot
of green plants on the right background
i actually
really manifested the idea
so you know it's like everyone's always
like how did you take an idea and then
start a business well it's how did you
even come up with the idea you know i
was in search of my idea and at the time
my life was not great i was selling fax
machines door-to-door i was living with
my mom i was like 25 years old and i
remember after a whole entire day of
being kicked out of office complexes
again all day or sometimes my business
card ripped up in my face i pulled off
the side of the road one day kathy and i
was like
i'm in the wrong movie like what just
happened
call the director call the producer this
is not my life this is not my movie and
i went home that night i wrote down my
strengths or what i thought i was good
at
and the only thing in the good column
really was sales
and i thought okay well i know i'm good
at selling what is it i like about
selling and i realized i like offering
something to someone that they need or
didn't know that they needed that can
improve their life or help them and
so in that moment i wrote down in my
journal i want to invent a product that
i can sell to millions of people that
will make them feel good
and
um and you know what and two years later
the idea came to me i always tell people
sometimes i get you know we'll have a
good um
quarterly conference call or something
and and wall street will like our
quarterly results and i'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and i
say thank you but what i'm really
thinking is
that quarter was baked three years ago i
right now i'm working on a quarter
that's going to reveal itself in 2021
sometime
and that's what you need to be doing you
need to be out sort of you know two or
three years in advance
and if you are and then why do i need to
make 100 decisions today if i make like
three good decisions a day that's enough
being treating people equally is not is
not the same
is not recognizing who they truly are
and taking advantage of their skills you
know and i've learned that through sin
i've learned that through all this and
you know like sin and i talk we'll be a
much better organization i'll be a
better exec i'll be a better investor
i'll be a better um
shark um because i recognize that you
know treating people equally is not the
same as treating them recognizing their
skills and their differences and for
this for this audience it's critically
important
you know
and i think there's an opportunity now
and i know hopefully you know people
like me will recognize that the old
white guys now newly old white guys that
are in positions of power
that
there are things that you can do that i
can't do that there are things you see
that i don't see
there are
opportunities that you can create
that i can't create
you know we were trying to sell to the
black community
through the mavs
with
multiple white men
we were trying to sell to moms with
multiple white men
it's not that they're not capable it's
not that they're not skilled
it's just everybody brings something
different to the table and as an
entrepreneur you have to recognize what
the differences are that you bring to
the table and you have to be brutally
honest with yourself right you can't lie
to yourself like we all lie to ourselves
as entrepreneurs but those differences
can be part of your unique skill set
like i talked about earlier and now i'm
finally starting to recognize those
things
and you know the one thing i know it's
going to make me a shitload more money
leadership is not only about inspiring
leadership is those people who join your
company
you have to create value for him you
have to making sure in three years
he will be different
not because his job is different because
if the people not different the products
will never be different
i told many people when they joined
alibaba i say guys
i don't know fortunate or unfortunate to
enjoy alibaba
we work much longer than the others
much harder
we had more problems than most of the
companies
if you can survive in alibaba you can
survive at any company in the world
because life is tough
we never promise
you would be rich
you will be successful you will probably
promote it
but we will promise you
you will be a problem
you have a wrong
you will make a mistake you have a
terrible boss we all promised
so you set the expectation
but have a good vision
so that is the way we manage
the company
and i think
when you hire good people the good
people believe the vision they will go
so when i visiting a company whether
it's a good ceo or not i do not listen
to the ceo
i listen to his people
if the people believe the vision all the
people believe this guy
if the people believe the vision
if the people believe this guy this
company has hope
a good
a good entrepreneur can always tell good
stories
i don't need to listen story from you
guys i can tell your people
right if your people
any young people in your company he can
tell me the vision
he can tell me what they're doing
that is a good company
that's leadership leadership making sure
everybody when they sleep
when they drink when they talk when they
go to toilet they talk your vision and
they believe it what's your attitude to
fear and risk
uh yeah you got it you got you got it
you got it you gotta you gotta take risk
the the the best way to stay out of
harm's way is to be the most dangerous
person in the room right i like that you
know yeah like
yeah do you ever though sometimes think
man i'm taking two bigger risks every
scary every deal i do yeah every deal it
make you feel alive
no i know i'm alive i just i just um
you know like when you take on an arena
and you're like i'm gonna book there's 5
000 people here okay
my my my gig did had seven times that
many people 35 000 people yeah i mean i
sold out an arena as big as jc and
beyonce would sell out the difference is
i had them there for three days they
have them there for two hours
on super bowl weekend
our biggest
football
you know
you guys laugh at our football but we
love it right so so the biggest
uh sports weekend
in the united states of america is super
bowl weekend i held my event on that
weekend freaking insane you don't need
150 iq to do what i do thank god you
know you don't need 140 you know 135 you
may need 115 or something like that and
and but you do need discipline
you have to wait until you see the fat
pitch to swing at
because investing is a no-call strike
game you know if i were a baseball
player and i only like pitches
two inches above my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like you can get called out on strikes
in baseball you have to you have to
swing at pitches that you you don't even
necessarily like particularly after the
count gets to two strikes
in business
you don't have to swing at anything you
can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 it
says general electric at 115 or so
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but it's a marvelous game to be
in because there are no called strikes
and you can simply wait for that one
time
in a month or six months or a year or
two or three years when you really know
what you're doing where you like the
price where you like the people running
the business
and then you swing and you only need a
few swings in your lifetime do you
remember how much your first server cost
you said oh yeah no 85
85
yeah and i remember that because um that
was the gating factor for us launching
new schools i i mean we had this
philosophy from the very beginning that
we didn't want to be this project it
wasn't even a company at the very
beginning but we didn't want to be
burning a lot of money right we weren't
planning on raising a lot of money we
didn't want to be one of these things
that raised a bunch of money and you
know was losing a bunch of money and
decided that we'd somehow pull it
through at the end and
um so you know so
85 for the first server put ads on the
site and the the ads at the beginning
were
we just were running some kind of ad
network and do you remember what the
first ad was
um
no i don't um
i don't i don't know how did you get ads
um
this was eduardo's job
was i mean with your ad sales yeah he
basically like he was responsible for
making sure that we had enough money to
keep things running in the beginning and
um
you know but basically i mean so it was
the server was 85
and you know dustin and i basically
worked on kind of efficiency and making
sure that we can fit more schools onto
each server and
eduardo worked on selling more ads or
making a deal so that we can get an ad
network so that way we can we can make
more money but then whenever we had more
money we rented another 85 a month
server and we kind of went from there
and um i don't know just it's just an
interesting way of seeing never spent
money you didn't have in the beginning
not in the beginning no and then i mean
even that was the constraint on your
growth rate how many new 85 dollars you
could get yeah and i mean it was
actually good because i i mean you know
sometimes it's really nice to have the
time to
get your product to be awesome and deal
with scaling problems and one of the
things that was interesting was um
you know at the time i don't know how
many people remember this but i mean
friendster was the service that had
massive scaling problems yeah you know
the idea was they were they grew quickly
and it was really hard for them to scale
and um you know the fact that we could
kind of go college by college and and
kind of optimize the service and make it
more efficient and offer new features
but make sure that they worked um i
think was really key i mean we're
talking about people who've never built
a company before we've never built any
large scale software
or anything so having that period where
we could just bake it
and you know people these days like to
talk about how these services grow super
quickly then facebook did grow quickly
but i think it took a year for us to get
a million users and we thought that that
was incredibly fast being an
entrepreneur is about taking risks but
it's about taking very calculated risks
and being you know protecting the
downside so i didn't quit my job selling
fax machines
until i had already invented the product
i was working on it at night and on the
weekends for two years i was driving
around north carolina where most hosiery
was made begging a bunch of
manufacturing plants to help make it and
i didn't quit my job until i had already
landed neiman marcus saks fifth avenue
and got a call from oprah
just a typical day
then i was like okay i feel confident to
quit but i needed the income that was
coming in and i needed my health care
benefits and i was working out of my
apartment in virginia highlands and i
ran spanx out of my apartment for two
and a half years
and it was crazy i mean i'd semi trucks
pulling up twice a week to this
apartment and my neighbors are like
what's happening what's going on but i
was so conservative with my finances in
the beginning i was very scrappy and
still am what is your thing and when did
you kind of understand what it was it
hasn't changed my thing is
learning learning whatever is new and
applying it in ways that other people
aren't thinking of and so when i start i
got fired from a job selling software
started a company and within six months
this is the early days of pcs i
recognized that okay we need to connect
pcs together back then you walked around
you had your 500 quarter inch floppy and
you know who would need to connect to pc
we started you know writing software for
local area networks became a systems
integrator 30 some million dollar run
rate and sold it to h r block and then
got to the internet okay let's look at
this internet thing someone's gonna need
to put audio and then video on there
great and then after yahoo did yahoo
right i'm like you know what i'm looking
at these big screen tvs that cost thirty
thousand dollars that are high
definition television sets and i'm
thinking you know what eventually
they're gonna follow the price
performance curve of traditional of
traditional um consumer electronics and
they're gonna come down to price so i
started the first all high definition tv
network called hdnet then i'm looking
and saying okay you know what it's like
2006 2007 and traditional television and
cable is going um digital i'm saying you
know what there's going to be more a lot
of storage space and first access
digital space that cable companies
aren't used to using so let's take a
movie production company that we created
and let's make it available for date
distribution where people can will pay
20 bucks
to the the cable company to watch this
brand new movie and we get to keep 10 of
it your stock at one point i think went
to 100 but then it went down to six or
something like that at the peak of the
internet bubble our stock peaked
somewhere around 113 dollars
and then after the internet bubble
uh
you know busted open our stock went down
to six it went from 113 to six in less
than a year so my annual shareholder
that year starts with a one word
sentence and that one word sentence is
the word ouch
so
most of those internet companies of the
dot com era are out of business
yeah
you survived what was that that made you
to survive and virtually the rest of
them are gone um i it's very that whole
period is very interesting because the
stock is not the company and the company
is not the stock and so as i watched the
stock fall
from 113 to 6 i was also watching all of
our internal business metrics number of
customers profit per unit
you know
everything you can imagine defects etc
every single thing about the business
was getting better and fast and so as
the stock price was going the wrong way
everything inside the company was going
the right way and um uh
i you know so i wasn't we didn't need to
go back to the capital markets we didn't
need more money the only reason you know
a financial uh bus like the internet
bubble bursting is it makes it really
hard to raise money but you know we
already had the money we needed so we
just needed to continue to progress i
kind of knew deep down inside like okay
i'm i'm created
for more in the sense of like i have
more to give and and more to create
um and more to serve and more to see
and i always kind of knew it
and i went through this really lifelong
journey though of like
like like knowing i i was kind of
created for more but doubting it anyway
and
kind of my whole life actually and maybe
a lot of people out there may be in the
same spot and it's kind of why i wrote
the book because i feel like
while it's my story of going from a girl
who didn't believe in herself to like
believing in herself and not not
trusting herself to learning actually
how to kind of like break through all
the self-doubt and hear that inner voice
and like and trust it everybody works
hard
and everybody has their own dreams
there is
there was a time
where i used to spend a lot of energy
wanting things
wanting things
of course it's easy for me to say oh
things don't define you because i got a
lot of things things nice i like them
but this is what i learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space
that you purposefully have come to earth
to claim for yourself so
around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning
uh sunday morning should have been in
church but i wouldn't
i was reading
the new york times review of the color
purple
and i thought whoa this sounds like a
really great book i got out of bed in my
pajamas put on my galoshes
and went to the store to get the copy of
the color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore bought every
book of the color purple i took the
books to the office and i said to
everybody y'all got to read this book oh
my god you got to read this book color
purple i needed a book club i didn't
have one
so i passed out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear
that somebody's gonna do a movie about
the color purple but i don't know
anybody in the movie business by this
time i was on am chicago i don't know
anybody i start praying to god god
please help me find a way to get into
color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as
as
divine law would have it quincy jones
comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one half of a
day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson claiming that
billie jean was their lover and that's
not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room
he was coming out of the shower
and the television in his hotel room is
on am chicago
there sits little chubby me
with my jared curl
on am chicago
quincy jones tells ruben cannon the
casting agent i think i found sophia so
i get a call
from ruben cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song
would you be interested to come and
audition and i say i have not been
praying for moon song
[Applause]
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well
i think you should come and and audition
so i go to audition you know movie
people they make everything all secret
steven spielberg didn't want anybody
know he was doing color purple so on the
outside of the script it says moon song
but i know all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus this is the color
purple
yes
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie oh that i'm
thinking prayer prayer works
[Applause]
[Music]
prayer works
[Applause]
but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time i auditioned in february
march
april may comes i haven't heard anything
so i call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon
i'm sorry sir i haven't heard anything i
expected to hear something by now and
reuben cannon
african-american man
says to me
you don't call me
i call you
and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying i can't believe that god has
played this trick on me i think
this is a trick
so i decide that this is because the fat
has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose
25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i
i i also
was trying to make peace with it
i said god i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says real actresses
have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track
at the fat farm
it starts to rain
you all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life i start praying
running around the track
and i keep hearing this noise and i i
can't there's nobody on the track but me
and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
[Applause]
it's my thighs
[Applause]
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
there's nobody on the track so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me
help me let it go help me let it go help
me let it go god help me let it go
and you ever did this prayer where you
say okay lord don't come and let it go
then you get up you go well i think i
still got a little bit of it
i did help me let it go
but i am not going to be able to see the
other actress
in my part i won't be able to see it
won't be able to see color purple just
can't never see it the rest of my life i
won't be able to see it
so then i started
i don't know where it came from
i surrender all
i
surrender all
all
to thee my
blessed savior
i
surrender
all i sang and i cried i sang and i
cried and i prayed some more
until i could reach the point where not
only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless the other actress
i can bless her
i can say
[Music]
[Applause]
i bless you i bless you i bless you with
this i surrender all
i
surrender all
all
to thee
my
blessed savior
i
surrender
and i tell you
in my greatest testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
[Applause]
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me anymore
it had no control over me anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power that was greater than i could
ever know the instant that happened
a woman comes running out of the
cafeteria
screaming oh free
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody can pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he said named
spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound
you could lose this part
[Applause]
no
problem do i have
[Applause]
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
[Applause]
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said you're
hired it's been
a lot of fun
you know there's tons of things that i'm
not good at and so the question is
always can i get somebody involved you
know
you know certain day-to-day management
things negotiating things political
things
scientific experts who really do have
the time to focus in on one thing
like i did in in my 20s and just really
really see all the the possibilities the
18 founders of alibaba a lot of people
think they are legendary something wow
you alibaba founders you must be super
good at
honestly
most of us cannot find jobs early days
we're not that smart
none of us graduate from a
you know a great university
but the thing is that
we are ready to learn
we believe in the future if we work
together if we will learn with improve
we'll be there i told them for the first
year everybody forget about that you
will be vp vice president right you will
always be a tiny manager in your life
because if we're successful
people will high they will be smarter
than us
if we only hire people who are stupid
than us and then we'll be in trouble
right so when we hire people who are
smarter than us the company will grow
you will be happy because this is the
mission that we have
so
i would say there's no best people in
the world that is suit
ready for you
the best of people is always you you
find the right people
working together
training him developing him and he
training you he if then you have a
chance to build a team what are the best
ways for youth to get started now in
securing their financial future
for
for what to secure their financial
future
for you youth oh well it's not it's not
very complicated uh
it goes back to
getting full use out of your own talents
first
i mean the difference between whether
you're going to be earning x or 2x or 3x
a year
uh 20 years from now uh
is going to be a function
of how well not how much talent you have
but how how well you use the talents you
already have
and
so that is
the your best financial future
is your own ability and and
and your
uh a capacity to
to use those abilities to their
potential
and they can't take that can't be taken
away from you they can't even tax it
i mean uh you know most things if if you
wanna you know a piece of real estate if
they double the taxes they double the
taxes and that changes your ownership in
the property because now in effect the
taxing authorities own more of it
because they've got a greater command on
the revenue stream uh the same thing
about
almost any asset you have
but
they they don't tax what's in your head
and they don't tax
your ability to
start performing when you when you get
to work in the morning and finish in the
evening uh to to your potential one of
the things that amazes me
is how people who really do perform well
just sort of jump out at you once you're
running a business when i got out of
school i thought you know everybody
would behave that way but they don't
most people sort of go
go through life in a sleepwalk and
and
if you don't
you will stand out so
the big the biggest thing for your
financial future is yourself i think
there's a problem in in western europe
where um
where failure is uh
it's it's too impossible to fail once
you fail you can never you can never
start over i think there's a there's an
opposite version of this in california
where i think sometimes people
are a little bit too facile about
failure because i i think it actually is
always incredibly damaging to people um
and if you work really hard at something
and it doesn't work um uh
that's you know that's that's going to
be
psychologically damaging you know people
have less confidence you there all sorts
of reasons why why that tends to be uh
that tends to be quite bad i think that
um i think when people
i don't think there's that much you
learn from failure by the way because um
it's it's typically over determined it's
like why is technology slowing down why
did you fail it's typically five
separate reasons you work with the wrong
people the idea was bad the timing was
wrong it wasn't a monopoly the product
didn't work
and okay next time i'm working with
different people you figure out one out
of the five things you're likely to fail
fail again so i think i think uh failure
is not something one can learn very much
from i think that's sort of a myth that
i i would challenge um but what i think
what i think you should do when you when
when something goes badly wrong is um
you just keep going uh you you do
something else uh and you don't dwell on
the past the last time i was on this
interview
i think i just started working out every
day and my body was hurting all the time
i was in pain constantly you didn't want
to do it you were struggling dude my
ankles hurt my knees hurt my back hurt
my like like i had constant pain in my
body why'd you keep doing it
doing what working out no that that
that's no that i wasn't working before
you started working my body was really
pain i wasn't using my body i didn't use
it and it started to abandon me oh like
i wasn't paying attention to it you know
and it's like okay dude
you don't you don't want to pay
attention to me i'm going to make you
maybe i don't pay attention to you
you know or maybe i'll make you pay
attention to me yeah and then i got i
went to a pt uh three days a week that
really didn't do anything and i said you
know what i need to take responsibility
for this if i want to fix something that
that that's the code of my life do you
want to fix something take
responsibility yeah do you take
responsive don't give it over to the
physical therapist the masseuse i was
trying the masseuse the masseuse never
helped me
i needed to put muscle on my bones
so i i hired a guy named anthony he came
i said you come to the you come to my
place every day
same time every day here's the money
here take the money here's the schedule
i'm never going to miss a day wow
he travels with you too or no no no
this was in the first year got it and
you know it's been 14 months
i have almost zero pain in my body
[Music]
if you want another amazing video on how
billionaires think check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there
you